full police officers arrived on the
scene they were there to investigate a
missing person but they were hit with a
hail of bullets two of the officers went
down and they were then killed and this
is perhaps the most shocking part
execution style the other two officers
went for cover one of them who had only
been out of the police academy for a
couple of months hitting High Grass and
then the suspects set fire to that grass
to try and flush her out and neighbor
arrived on the scene he was shot dead
shot in the back and then it was around
another six hours some 16 police
officers arrived to try and get this
Siege this Ambush under control in the
end the three suspects were killed now
two of them were brothers and the third
was a woman one of them was a primary
school a principal from a remote area of
New South Wales this case of course is
Raising all sorts of questions and we're
not sure yet of the motive it's really
gripped large parts of Australia about
exactly how all of this came about but
the police commissioner for the state of
Queensland has said that those two
police officers who were killed never
stood a chance